if you're even slightly a fan of
spider-man you're in for a treat with
Sony's new animated movie there's enough
hidden away inside the film to keep
surprising viewers on their second third
or even fourth watches here are just a
few of the Easter eggs you might have
missed in spider-man into the spider
verse while spider verse is ultimately
an origin story for Miles Morales the
spotlight does get shared with other
spider people the first hero audiences
are introduced to is the Peter Parker of
miles as universe the movie starts off
with this Peters narration catching
viewers up on the broad strokes of the
spider-man story during Peters
recounting of his exploits as a
superhero the movie revisits several
classic set pieces from the Sam Raimi
spider-man cluding spider-man's heroic
train rescue the time Doctor Octopus
through a car through a window and the
much derided sequence of an evil Peter
Parker strutting around in spider-man 3
shooting everyone some finger guns
everyone knows that Marvel loves those
classic Stan Lee cameos but some of the
shoutouts to other important artists
from the company's history can often be
harder to notice spider-verse provides a
bit of a call-out for two other figures
who were crucial to spider-man's
development when miles is on the train
shortly after discovering his powers he
pulls out his phone and Scrolls through
the contacts passing by a conspicuous
entry for B Bendis a reference to Brian
Michael Bendis who co-created miles with
artists Erica Kelly in 2011 later in a
similar moment with Jeffersons Geoff
Scrolls by an entry for Steve Ditko who
co-created the original spider-man with
Stanley in 1962 though miles is Brooklyn
born and raised he also seems to be a
fan of the chicago-based MC chance the
rapper with a poster for his mixtape
coloring book appearing in miles his
room amusingly the distinctive baseball
cap chance wears on the real-life cover
with a number 3 on it indicating that
the mixtape as his third release has
been changed in miles alternate universe
to the number four the implication is
that the chance of this universe is
slightly more prolific than the version
we know maybe miles is universe just put
a lot more emphasis on the lil B
collaboration we all know that
spider-man is more than just a character
he's a lucrative multimedia property and
into the spider-verse has fun with that
fact
part of Peter Parker's intro to the
movie focuses on the extensive library
of Spider Murch that's been created over
the course of his crime-fighting career
with one of the most amusing products
being the Spider Man Christmas album but
this isn't a joke that was made for the
movies it's actually a joke from real
life the album in the movie is a
reference to a real spider-man album
that was released in 1975 a rock opera
from the label Lifesong records called
spider-man rock reflections of a hero
it sounds like Jefferson Airplane
singing jaunty songs about how no one's
got a crush on Peter Parker it's kind of
Awesome and in some alternate universe
it's probably a chart-topping hit there
have been so many spider-man suit
designs over the years at this point
that you could spend days putting
together a list of your favorites into
the spider-verse showcases a number of
alternate costumes inside of Aunt May
secret Spider lair several of the suits
visible in the background are cold from
Spidey's long comic book history and
also show up in the spider-man ps4 game
particularly the advanced suit with the
white logo that was made just for the
game you can also spot suits reminiscent
of the black and green stealth big-time
suit the electro proof suit the black
suit from secret war and even a look
similar to the black dust suit and the
most humorous suit which features a
clunky looking superhero cape
originally appeared in Marvel Comics
what if number 19 published in 1980 I
think this is a at separate points in
the movie both Peter Parker and Miles
Morales take a break from their
crime-fighting on the head of the
Panther s gargoyle jutting off the side
of some New York City architecture Peter
has some coffee and reads the newspaper
while miles strikes a pose highly
reminiscent of another superhero
T'Challa himself the Black Panther the
movie features imagery that originally
appeared on a poster for the Black
Panther movie released during the 2017
San Diego Comic Con in that image
T'Challa can be seen in his full black
panther suit looking out over the
horizon under soft lighting as he flexes
his glutes for the camera do you think
miles is dimension has its own Marvel
Cinematic Universe Miles his police
officer father Jefferson Davis presents
himself as a guy who likes law and order
so what better way to indicate his
allegiances than with the reference to
the TV show Law & Order in the beginning
of the movie Myles gets a ride to the
vision sporting school on his first day
from
or said in his police car the license
plate for Jeff's car is RFD nine six
zero which is actually a reference to
the detectives vehicles in the original
Law & Order series which always featured
the same license plate through the
show's entire run just like in real life
there's a lot going on in Spider versus
Time Square one billboard in the
neighborhood is an advertisement for a
Broadway show called hi hello which is
actually reference to some other work
from a member of the movies cast the
advertisement is a take on the real-life
show oh hello on Broadway which starred
comedians Nick Kroll and John Mulaney
Mulaney of course is a part of the
spider-verse movie as the voice actor of
Peter porker the spectacular spider hand
I'm right here shortly after all of the
spider people converge they meet for a
pep talk inside of miles dorm room which
he shares with a roommate when the
roommate returns unexpectedly they all
dart up to the ceiling shuffling around
the corners to avoid being seen
while the roommate reads from a comic
book you may notice that the comic book
refers to a story called imagine that
there was more than one spider-man
imagine that indeed while Marvel comics
never put out and imagine that line of
comics the company does have a series
called what is this speculative line of
comics published since 1977 usually
focuses on weird one-off stories
allowing writers and readers to explore
wild hypothetical scenarios such as what
if spider-man had joined the Fantastic
Four of course something just like that
actually happened many years later so
clearly the idea was pretty good the
post-credits scene for spider-verse
thrillingly introduces one of the best
and coolest spider people miguel O'Hara
aka spider-man 2099 at first it seems as
though the stinger will be setting up a
futuristic spider-verse sequel but that
notion quickly sails out the window when
Miguel travels to the goofy alternate
universe of Earth 67 in Marvel Comics
Canon this world is the home of the
cornball 1967 spider-man cartoons and
the sequence quickly becomes a big joke
when Miguel arrives he immediately
encounters the 67 spider-man after which
they proceed to recreate the spider-man
pointing at spider-man meme for what
feels like a full minute and then the
movie ends it's arguably the weirdest
funniest post-credit scene in a genre
that is full of them and the perfect way
to send off the silly love letter of a
move
[Music]